Now this quiz is an open-ended quiz. And in
this, I am giving you the same example, the
my fun example of me purchasing a trip to
got to India for the Christmas holidays. And, so I
am showing you all the communication events. The communication
events are shown by these lines here, A to
B, C to D, and so on. And this
is a textual ordering of events. In, that same process.
So these are eventually the same process. And the question
that I'm going to ask you, like I said, it's an
open-ended question. I want you to identify all the events,
that are connected by, the happened-before relationship. I told you that
this is the notation that I'm using for happened-before relationship.
So I want you identify all the events. And I'm showing
you a whole bunch of events starting from A working
your way through to L. So all these events. And what
I want you to do is identify all the events
that are connected by this happened before the relationship. You can
choose to connect both events that are directly connected that
happened before, as well as
transitively connected what happened before relationship.
And in the second box, I want you to identify
all the events. That are concurrent events in the system. So
there's a whole bunch of events here, and I want
you to identify the events that you think are concurrent events.
Meaning there is no way for, for us to assert
that there is any ordering of the events in the system.